[Musique]
donc
c'est tout le monde
[Musique]
étant donné les résultats des études d'efficacité,
le ministère de la Santé
poursuivra sa vaccination de phase un prévue
ciblant les agents de santé utilisant le
vaccin johnson et johnson
au lieu du vaccin astrazeneca,
le vaccin johnson et johnson s'est
avéré efficace
contre la variante 501 yv2
et les processus d'approbation nécessaires pour une
utilisation en afrique du sud et
[Musique]
nous avons obtenu 9 millions de doses de
vaccin johnson et johnson
le premier lot d'environ 80  000 doses
arriveront dans le pays la semaine prochaine, d'
autres envois arriveront au cours
des
quatre prochaines semaines, totalisant un demi-million de
vaccins johnson et johnson
[Music] à
bientôt